[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
Samstagabend willkommen schön dass Sie
dabei sind Sport gibt es auch in der
Sendung mit Norbert Lehmann
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
der Streit übers geplante Bürgergeld
wird Schärfe die SPD wirft der Union vor
bei den Berechnungen zu lügen
die Tafeln schlagen Alarm immer mehr
bedürftige benötigen Hilfe viele müssen
abgewiesen werden
und Kampf gegen die Erderwärmung die
internationale Klimakonferenz steht vor
kaum lösbaren Aufgaben und das
Gastgeberland Ägypten in der Kritik
[Musik]
es ist eine der großen Sozialreformen
der Bundesregierung ab Januar soll das
Bürgergeld Hartz IV ablösen Arbeitslose
bekämen dann mehr Unterstützung und
weniger Druck im Jobcenter doch die
Union ist dagegen sie argumentiert
Arbeit würde sich dann nicht mehr lohnen
Geringverdiener bekamen bekämen dann
kaum mehr als Empfänger des Bürgergeldes
das ist ein Fake News sagt die SPD Diana
zimmermann
es sollte ein Befreiungsschlag für die
Arbeitsagenturen werden und das
unbeliebte hartz-iv-ablösen das
Bürgergeld geplante Einführung schon im
Januar 2023 weniger Sanktionen bessere
Unterstützung und 50 Euro mehr im Monat
doch die Union behauptet so lohne sich
das Arbeiten nicht mehr und will im
Bundesrat blockieren für den
SPD-Vorsitzenden spielt sie damit
Geringverdiener und Arbeitssuchende
gegeneinander aus
und wer sich so verhält wer den Weg von
Donald Trump der Verbreitung von Fake
News einschlägt wer der Meinung ist man
müsste das Land Spalten der hat nichts
mehr in der politischen Mitte dieses
Landes verloren die Regierung hatte als
Kompromissangebot erst gestern
Regelungen verschärft so sollen etwa die
Zuschüsse zur Energiekosten für
bürgergeld-empfänger nicht mehr
unbegrenzt erstattet werden die Union
befürwortet zwar die geplante Erhöhung
der Regelsätze sieht aber beim
Bürgergeld insgesamt einen
Konstruktionsfehler am Beginn des Bürger
jetzt auf jede Möglichkeit der
Durchsetzung von Mitwirkungen durch
Leistungskürzung zu verzichten an diesem
entscheidenden Webfehler ist will die
Ampel nichts ändern und damit geht
dieser Gesetzentwurf in die Irre für die
Linke dagegen sind Sanktionen insgesamt
ein Fehler und die Zahlungen viel zu
niedrig die Hartz IV-Reform hat damals
nicht dazu geführt dass mehr Arbeit im
Land entstanden ist sondern das
massenhaft Armut im Land entstanden ist
und es braucht sowohl höhere Löhne als
auch eine Grundsicherung von der die
Menschen in Würde leben können das
Gesetz soll Ende November durch den
Bundesrat gehen der Streit droht den
Start des Bürgergeldes und damit auch
der Regelsatzerhöhung zu verzögern
wie viele Menschen hierzulande
Unterstützung brauchen zeigt sich an den
Tafeln noch nie haben sie so vielen
Bedürftigen geholfen etwa zwei Millionen
Menschen bekommen dort Lebensmittel die
sonst weggeworfen würden die Folge des
Ansturms jede dritte Tafel ist so
überlastet dass ein Aufnahmestopp
verhängt werden musste aus Potsdam
berichtet Jan Meyer
vor der Potsdamer Tafel ist der Andrang
besonders groß monatelang nahm sie keine
weiteren Bedürftigen mehr an nun werden
neue berechtigungskarten ausgegeben
viele Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine sind
hier Jaroslav kajuk stellt sich an für
seine Frau und seine drei Kinder
unsere Familie bekommt zwar Hilfe aber
die Lebensmittel werden immer teurer
fast alles geben wir dafür aus
200 freiwillige helfen in Potsdam mit
sie können nicht mehr Lebensmittel aus
Supermärkten als bisher verteilen doch
der Leiter der Tafel fand einen Weg
weiteren Menschen zu helfen
in der Woche haben wir bis zum
Aufnahmestopp ca 1.500 Abholer versorgt
diese durch den Aufnahmestopp haben wir
uns jetzt entschlossen den aufzuheben
zum ersten November und können jetzt
noch 200 zusätzliche Haushalte für die
Woche aufnehmen wir fahren reduzieren
ein kleines bisschen die Menge können
dafür aber mehrere Leute mit bedienen
und das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut
Obst Gemüse und Brot nach einer Stunde
ist alles verteilt die fast 1000 Tafeln
in Deutschland erwarten mit Sorge den
bevorstehenden Winter wir glauben das
noch mehr Menschen zu den Tafeln kommen
werden dass noch mehr geflüchtete aus
den Kriegsgebieten zu uns kommen werden
noch mehr Menschen durch Inflationen und
Preissteigerungen gefordert sind eben
halt zu sparen wo sie können und bei
manchen ist das einfach immer der Weg
dann zu den Tafeln für die Helfer wird
die Arbeit nicht einfacher doch immer
mehr Menschen wie jaroslavkatschuk sind
darauf angewiesen dass sie Woche für
Woche hier mit Lebensmitteln versorgt
werden
mehr bedürftige Energie und Klimakrise
Streit um Bürgergeld reichlich
Herausforderungen für eine
Regierungspartei wie die SPD die möchte
aber auch nach vorn schauen neue Ideen
kreieren darüber diskutierten die
Sozialdemokraten heute auf ihrem
sogenannten debattenkonvent auch mit dem
Bundeskanzler Klaus Brodbeck war dabei
natürlich schaut die Partei vor allem
auf ihn der Kanzler führt die Regierung
nicht die SPD doch von der Zukunft
seiner Partei lässt sich das auch in
diesem Rahmen kaum trennen Olaf Scholz
muss vor allem erklären
wie können wir das rechtfertigen wie
rechtfertigen sie das dass sie mit einem
Staat wie China der die Menschenrechte
sehr verachtet trotzdem
Wirtschaftsabkommen machen es wäre kein
guter Rat zu sagen
wir die Europäer oder die Amerikaner die
das ja auch nicht tun ziehen uns aus
China zurück es ist nur wichtig dass wir
uns nicht abhängig machen ich bin Finn
aus
Berlin ist warum wir das Tempolimit noch
nicht umgesetzt haben weil es würde CO2
einsparen Menschen leben würden dadurch
geschützt und Menschen würden nicht
sterben und es wäre kostenlos
diese Forderung steht ja in den
Beschlüssen der SPD und auch in unserem
Wahlprogramm wir haben keine
gesetzgebungsmehrheit zustande gebracht
die SPD will sich öffnen inhaltlich und
für neue Gruppen selbst nicht Mitglieder
dürfen mitmachen er kann jeder auch auf
Augenhöhe mit dem Bundeskanzler und den
Parteivorsitzenden denen auch die
Meinung sagen auch wenn man etwas ganz
anders sieht Input von außen also ich
bin total dankbar dass viele
Wissenschaftlerinnen Wissenschaftler
internationale Gäste auch Vertreter aus
der Wirtschaft aus Gewerkschaften eben
dabei sind die Partei ringt um Themen
und Positionen seit elf Monaten stellt
die SPD wieder den Kanzler darauf allein
aber will sie sich für die Zukunft nicht
verlassen
Drohnenangriffe auf Kiew und andere
ukrainische Städte lange wurde darüber
spekuliert jetzt hat der Iran zugegeben
Drohnen an Russland geliefert zu haben
allerdings in geringer Zahl und bereits
vor dem Krieg so der iranische
Außenminister von einem Einsatz dort
wisse er aber nichts unterdessen gingen
heute die Kämpfe im Osten und Süden der
Ukraine weiter über den Kriegstag
255 Meike verladen joland
sie bereiten sich auf einen blutigen
Kampf vor ukrainische Soldaten nördlich
von hassson an der Front an einen
russischen Rückzug aus der strategisch
wichtigen Stadt am Fluss denipro im
Süden glauben Sie nicht
dafür dass sie sich zurückziehen aber
sie warten nur darauf dass wir einen
ersten Schritt machen um dies dann für
Gegenschläge zu nutzen
der Krieg geht also weiter Experten aus
den USA halten sogar eine verdeckte
Fortführung der russischen
Teilmobilmachung für wahrscheinlich
obwohl Moskau am Dienstag das Ende
verkündigt hatte auch Ukrainisch
Präsident selenski glaubt russland werde
noch mehr Menschen in den Krieg schicken
Russland lässt zehn oder 100.000
Menschen mehr im Fleischwolf sterben ob
mobilisiert oder in Form von Söldnern
laut ukrainischen Angaben finden die
schwersten Kämpfe derzeit in der Region
Donezk um die Städte bachmut und Solidar
statt noch halten die ukrainischen
Truppen den russischen Angriffen dort
stand und sie feuern zurück auf Russland
Soldaten mit russischen Waffen die Ihnen
bereits im März in die Hände fielen
auch im Zentrum von bachmut sind die
Gefechte rund um die Stadt Städter
Begleiter die die bleiben werden mit
Hilfsgütern versorgt doch immer mehr
Menschen entscheiden sich dafür bachmut
hinter sich zu lassen
[Applaus]
mehr Hilfe für die Ukraine forderten
heute zahlreiche Demonstranten in Köln
unter dem Titel Marsch für die Freiheit
zogen am Nachmittag tausende durch die
Innenstadt auch um die systemkritischen
Proteste im Iran zu unterstützen die
seit Wochen andauern in Berlin
bekundeten iranisch-deutsche Ärzte und
Apotheker ihre Solidarität mit
medizinischen Personal in Iran
morgen geht's los mit der
Weltklimakonferenz zwei Wochen lang
beraten 40.000 teilnehmende wie der
Kampf gegen die erderhitzung verstärkt
werden kann Gastgeber ist diesmal
Ägypten was die Sache nicht einfacher
macht denn in Ägypten sind meinungs- und
Versammlungsfreiheit massiv
eingeschränkt politische Gegner werden
weggesperrt und Klimaschutz findet
vorwiegend am konferenzgelände statt
goldene Atay berichtet
Sharm el Sheikh ein exklusiver Badeort
fernab der stickigen Hauptstadt Ägyptens
keine Klimakonferenz wurde mehr
überwacht als die die morgen hier
beginnt Normalbürger haben keinen
Zutritt in der Klima muss der Stadt
fahren e-busse machen Solarzellen Licht
und ist das Fahrradfahren überall
möglich etliche Bäume wurden gepflanzt
woanders im Land fallen alte Bäume und
Parks ehrgeizigen Bauplänen zum Opfer
ganz Ägypten gleicht eine Großbaustelle
die Militärführung lässt immer mehr
Straßen Brücken Siedlungen aus dem Boden
stampfen für die Klimabilanz des
Gastgebers ist das verheerend
die menschenrechtsbilanz ebenso Ägyptens
Regierung hat Menschenrechtlern keinen
Einlass zur Konferenz gewährt ein
Kleinert of fear ein Klima der Angst
unterdrückt die Stimmen aller vom
Klimawandel besonders betroffenen
Gruppen und Menschen hier
zehntausende politische Gefangene sitzen
in den Gefängnissen der prominenteste
unter ihnen der demokratieaktivist Allah
ab der fata verschärft ab morgen seinen
Hungerstreik und verzichtet auf Wasser
kritiker bezweifeln ob eine
Klimakonferenz in einem autoritären
Staat erfolgreich und glaubwürdig sein
kann zwar hat Ägyptens Regierung in
diesem Jahr hunderte politische
Gefangene freigelassen aber aktuell
erlebt das Land eine neue festnahmewelle
weil Oppositionelle für diese Woche zu
Protesten aufgerufen haben am
Konferenzort ist für Demonstrationen nur
eine abgelegene spezialzone vorgesehen
jeder Demonstrant muss vorher
registriert sein
auf der Klimakonferenz soll es auch um
die Verantwortung der reichen Nationen
gehen das ungerechte ist ja dass die
ärmsten Länder kaum zum Klimawandel
beitragen aber am heftigsten unter den
Folgen leiden Pakistan zum Beispiel bei
den Überschwemmungen im Sommer starben
mehr als 1600 Menschen Millionen wurden
obdachlos und die Lage ist immer noch
katastrophal Norman Odenthal
Kader hat es erwischt ein Moskito ein
kleiner Stich nur das Fieber ist hoch
die Diagnose klar Malaria sie tun was
sie können Versicherte Arzt aber sie
arbeiten an den Grenzen ihrer
Möglichkeiten es gibt zu viele die ihre
Hilfe brauchen
die Masse an Patienten ist einfach zu
groß unser Krankenhaus ist total
überlaufen die Menschen kommen alle aus
den überflutungsgebieten es sind viel zu
viele wir haben nicht genug Medikamente
und wir sind nicht genug Ärzte um das zu
schaffen
6-8 Wochen etwa liegt der Höhepunkt der
Flut schon zurück das Wasser ist
inzwischen gewichen aber Pakistan erlebt
eine Katastrophe nach der Katastrophe
die Zerstörung der Hunger Seuchen wie
Malaria Cholera denke die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation ist
alarmiert
die Flut hat Pakistan an den Rand des
Abgrunds gebracht Krankheiten breiten
sich aus Nahrungsmittel fehlen die
Wirtschaft liegt am Boden und der Winter
steht bevor 8 Millionen Menschen
brauchen dringend medizinische Hilfe
der Klimawandel wird Pakistan immer
häufiger immer härter treffen sagen die
Experten das können Fluten sein genauso
wie Dürre die Zukunft ist unberechenbar
nur Gutes verspricht sie nicht aber wie
damit leben
erst sind meine Felder in der Hitze
verdorrt dann kam der heftige Regen das
Wetter wechselt von einem Extrem ins
andere und von unserer Ernte ist kaum
noch was geblieben alles ist verrottet
Klimawandel ein großes Wort das für
manche noch immer abstrakt klingt nicht
für Pakistan und die Menschen die dort
überleben wollen
die Lage in Pakistan eines der Themen
morgen bei der Klimakonferenz in Ägypten
worum es geht und wo die Welt im Kampf
gegen die Erderwärmung steht alles
wichtige zum Gipfeltreffen gibt es in
der ZDF heute App
die türkisch-deutsche Schriftstellerin
Emine Sevgi östermar ist mit dem
diesjährigen Georg-Büchner-Preis
ausgezeichnet worden die Jury würdigte
östermar als herausragende Autorin die
die deutschsprachige Literatur seit drei
Jahrzehnten mit Romanen Erzählungen und
Theaterstücken bereichere der mit 50.000
Euro dotierte Preis ist eine der
bedeutendsten literarischen
Auszeichnungen im deutschen Sprachraum
und jetzt zum Skispringen Norbert aber
das Anfang November schon ein bisschen
komisch alles wegen der Fußball-WM die
wäre sonst mit dem Saisonauftakt der
Springer kollidiert die Lösung
Vorverlegung des weltcup-staats im
polnischen Wissler und Matten statt
Kunstschnee die deutschen Springer heute
bin ich erfolgreich
so früh ging es noch nie los noch dazu
ohne Schnee doch das kennt der
Oberstdorfer karl-geiger aus der
Saisonvorbereitung sein kurzer erster
Sprung hat er mit Form Problemen zu tun
der Gesamtweltcup II des Vorjahres
scheidet im ersten Durchgang als 34 aus
Konstantin Schmidt verpasst als Sechster
bei Halbzeit seine podestchancen und
wird 16 keiner der sechs deutschen
Starter landet unter den besten Zehn zum
Sieg springt David Kubatzki der Pole ist
in beiden Durchgängen vorne und gewinnt
nach 132 einhalb Metern unter den Augen
von Staatspräsident anje du da vor dem
Norweger Halver gerade und Stefan Kraft
aus Österreich erst Anfang April wird
die Saison zu Ende gehen so spät wie
noch nie
bei den turnweltmeisterschaften in
Liverpool hat Elisabeth Seitz nur knapp
eine Medaille verpasst die Stufenbarren
Europameisterin erkämpfte an ihrem
Paradegerät den vierten Platz seit zwar
nach einer corona-infektion erst kurz
vor der WM wieder fit geworden
Weltmeisterin wurde die
Titelverteidigerin welche un aus China
zur Fußball-Bundesliga da hat Bayern
zumindest vorübergehend die
Tabellenspitze erobert durch den Sieg
bei Hertha BNC BSC hier die bisherigen
Ergebnisse des 13 spieltags
Hertha gegen München 2:3 ist folgen drei
weitere Heimniederlagen Augsburg
Frankfurt 1:2 Hoffenheim Leipzig 1:3 und
Mainz Wolfsburg 0:3 einziger Heimsieg
bislang heute das 130 der Dortmunder im
Revier Derby gegen Bochum das Abendspiel
Bremen gegen Schalke und bereits gestern
der 3:1 Sieg der Gladbacher gegen
Stuttgart Blick auf die Tabelle die
Bayern also erster Union Berlin kann
aber morgen die Führung zurückerobern
Dortmund klettert auf Rang 3 dahinter
Freiburg Frankfurt und Leipzig
Gladbach jetzt siebter die zweite
Tabellenhälfte die beginnt mit Mainz ja
und unten alles unverändert Leverkusen
16 vor Bochum und Schlusslicht Schalke
und das Abendspiel Bremen gegen Schalke
natürlich bei uns ausführlich zu sehen
im Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu
Gast Eintracht Kapitän Sebastian Rode
und im Spitzenspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Frauen da hat
München souverän in Freiburg gewonnen
Bayern mit dem 1:0 durch Lea Schüler in
der 21 Minute die Münchnerin Spiel
beherrschend die Entscheidung dann in
der 70 Minute durch den Treffer von
Sarah Zadrazil zum 3:0 entstand der FCB
klettert auf Platz 2 der SC rutscht auf
Rang 5 und spitzenreiter sind weiterhin
die wolfsburgerring ich danke bitte und
wir haben jetzt noch ein kleines
fernseh-highlight aus Chile für Sie
während ein Reporter gerade live aus
einem Wohnviertel über Diebstähle
berichtet nähert sich ein neugieriger
Papagei erst steht er dem Reporter die
Show und danach auch noch sein Equipment
ließ es allerdings später wieder fallen
schmeckte wohl nicht
der Sonntag bringt morgen im Nordwesten
Wolken mit etwas Regen sonst bleibt es
trocken mehr hat gleich Christa Augen um
viertel nach elf das heute journal mit
Christian Sievers das komplette heute
Team wünscht Ihnen einen schönen
Samstagabend bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend ein Tief kreiselt über dem
Mittelmeer und sorgt hierfür Unwetter
bei uns ist dagegen heute ein
zwischenhochwirksam aber schon morgen
erreichen uns die Ausläufer dieses Tiefs
über dem Atlantik ein ehemaliger
Hurrikan Martin und mit ihm frischt
jetzt heute Nacht im Nordwesten der Wind
schon weiter auf an der See wird er
stark böch hier ist es auch dicht
bewölkt mit leichtem Regen sonst aber
oft klar und vor allem im Süden und
Teilen der Mitte kann sich morgens Nebel
und Hochnebel bilden und dieser
Zweiteilung sieht man auch am
Temperaturgefälle an der Nordsee unter
den Wolken gibt es 10 Grad in Teilen
Süddeutschlands ist es sogar leicht
frostig bis minus zwei Grad dazu gibt es
hier verbreitet Bodenfrost morgen
erreichen wir ähnlich wie heute sieben
bis dreizehn Grad im Nebel kann es
kühler bleiben und der hält sich im
windschwachen Südosten noch am längsten
sonst frischt der Südwind auf die dich
Stärken im Nordwesten mit dem leichten
Regen breiten sich im Tagesverlauf über
den Westen aus sonst ist es aber trocken
und die Sonne schaut hervor richtig
sonnig ist es sogar im Osten des Landes
in der neuen Woche geht es
leichtwechselhaft weiter eine Mischung
aus vielen Wolken etwas Sonne und etwas
Regen im Nordwesten dazu ist es windig
und abseits von Nebel auch zu warm für
diese Jahreszeit tschüss